growing Fallout over the newly released
Jeffrey Epstein documents shocking
high-profile names are being revealed
from A-list Hollywood celebrities to
Titans of industry and even former US
presidents and that's just the start a
second batch could be released at any
moment we'll keeping an eye on that one
name that appears 50 times in the
documents is former President Bill
Clinton one of Epstein's accusers Joanna
scherg testifying that the pedophile
told her that Clinton quote likes them
young referring to girls
the lawyer for the victims telling Jesse
that the documents raised new questions
about the former president the victim
reported being on a helicopter with him
and with uh
Maxwell um and um there's another
statement that she made that uh EPS uh
Clinton was on the island which is very
different than what we'd heard
previously we were that he wasn't on the
island again hard to say who who to
believe of course but um he was on the
line on the island but didn't take the
bait in other words didn't have relation
sexual relationships with any of any of
the girls Bill Clinton denies ever
visiting Epstein's Island sherg also
detailing alleged abuse at the hands of
Britain's prince Andrew saying that he
groped her breast and accuses the prince
of having group sex with minors prince
Andrew previously denied misconduct and
settled a sexual abuse case by Epstein
accuser Virginia gfra last year the
explosive document dump also name drops
170 of Epstein's visitors including
Michael Jackson magician David
Copperfield and former president Donald
Trump we do want to make clear that most
of the people named in the suit they've
not been accused of wrongdoing this J
can you maybe also well say whatever you
want of course but why these documents
are coming out okay that's that's the an
excellent question look there was a
lawsuit where a Virginia jeffra sued uh
gain Maxwell for defamation when galain
said she lied about the sexual abuse so
this lawsuit took place in 2016 as with
and with most lawsuits civil there's a
deposition ahead of time for some reason
from 2016 until today those depositions
were sealed judge Loretta presco who's a
federal judge made the decision that she
was going to unseal them but for two and
some say possibly three Jane do who who
are saying that harm might come to them
so there there there will be as a result
of this release a rolling release of
more names going forward so what we have
so far is not all of them I would
caution everybody that this is not the
black book right the black book is now
in the possession of the Department of
Justice and when I hear galain Maxwell
say you know for all this the only
person who's in jail is a female my
response to her would be you have had
the black book you could have cut a deal
or maybe Jeffrey Epstein you know didn't
hang himself and she doesn't want to end
up in the same situation the most
shocking name uh to come out was Stephen
Hawking okay that was that was a stunner
and what is amazing because you could
say we don't know and we can't attribute
wrongdoing to any of them but Epstein
actually wrote an email to Maxwell and
he said you can issue a reward to any of
Virginia's friends that's a victim
acquaintances or family that come
forward help her prove help prove her
allegations are false the strongest is a
Clinton dinner and the new version in
the Virgin Islands that Stephen Hawkins
participated in an underage orgy so
there is an email from Epstein uh to
Maxwell saying pay them to shut that one
down think also about the fact that
you've got David Copperfield Bill
Clinton Michael Jackson Kevin spacy what
is common among all of them they've all
been previous ly accused of sexual
assault or some sexual deviancy uh Bill
Clinton with a college student uh
Copperfield with an underage
teenager Uh Kevin spacy the same and
Michael Jackson and accused pedophile so
um the the the bottom line here it's the
bankers that these girls would not
necessarily recognize they don't know
the network of banks that allowed the
money and they in spite of the sor the
suspected uh um uh account U SARS the
suspicious activity reports in spite of
those that network is what allowed this
pedophile and he is a pedophile to
continue to do business after his
conviction in Florida Jesse what else
did you learn last night as it broke
right around your show well the judge is
right this is a very small window into
the world of Epstein besides being a
benefactor of the sciences and a wealth
manager he was an intelligence asset and
that's why the federal government signed
this non-prosecution agreement with him
many many years ago because he was
working for the CIA possibly mad
remember galain Maxwell's father who
drowned mysteriously off of his yacht
was also involved with MI6 with mad and
possibly the CIA so the intelligence
world is always overlapped
with the
aristocratic political Finance celebrity
circles and they use sexual currency as
leverage but what makes this sexual
currency so potent and so illicit is
that the girls were underage and no one
seems to care about the girls all the
media seems to care about is making
political hay out of these
names and they're so focused on linking
Donald Trump to this when Bill Clinton
has so much more exposure to Jeffrey Epi
Donald
Trump actually
provided information to the lawyer of
some of these victims that ended up
checking out he did it without having to
be deposed he didn't fight a subpoena
like Bill Clinton did and it was his
Department of Justice that ended up
arresting Jeffrey Epstein he cut off a
relationship he had with Jeffrey Epstein
a very very long time ago meanwhile Bill
Clinton lied about being on these
flights I have someone that told me they
saw him on the island Bill Clinton was
photographed getting massage by one of
the victims of Jeff so the intelligence
committee still is trying to clean this
up and it just saddens me that no one's
thinking about these victims and
everyone's covering up for the royal
family the politicians the bureau
Langley and the media has just been
disgraceful in their coverage $290
million went to the victims from JP
Morgan sorry 290 million 290 million
okay Greg you got some thoughts over
this is the first I heard of Stephen
Hawking being accused of sex with
underage girls yes I guess he really did
prefer A Brief History of Time all right
I listened to this I listened to this
news I feel like I showed up at Target
on Saturday after Black Friday all the
good stuff has been cleaned out all
that's left are two socks and a moomoo
you know it's clear it's all the stuff
that you already knew right yep and and
it's like it's stuff the stuff that
matters the real black male stuff
was probably removed far far earlier
it's like a bowl of Halloween candy at
the end of the night all you got are
like Necco Wafers and dots there's no
surp I don't think there's any surprises
there there's no Dana Perino right
didn't know no no there we have photos
of you uh handing in a book a day
overdue at the library I still feel
guilty but I mean honestly Bill Clinton
at Epstein Island that's as shocking as
Mike penson church so we saw that coming
for me it feels like the UFO stories
right there always like for a couple
years now it's been like a series of
tantalizing hints at something else
perhaps to keep us occupied with the
morsels rather than the meat and what's
the meat as Jesse might be alluding to a
larger bigger operation that had its
tentacles everywhere and it's run by
Intel agencies to hold on to power and
to wield influence right I mean there's
there's so many crazy things happening
in this world that's unexplained you
could point to our our immigration
policy which is a mess everybody agrees
it's a mess no one's doing anything
about it perhaps a lot of these insane
actions are because people are forced to
do things because someone has something
on them maybe it's not you know the
filter isn't oppressed versus oppressor
but it's the compromiser versus the
compromised last word of you
Jessica not a ton of new information
obviously but deeply disturbing to see
it all over again and to feel the
gravity and the breth of this Scandal
and how many lives it touched how many
people we all here in New York we have
rubbed Shoulders by some of these people
walk down the street they've been out
and about and some of them you know
still have very highflying careers and
it'll be interesting to see what happens
to them a few people have obviously lost
their careers in the last few uh years
as a result um I would say though on the
prince Andrew front that I think this is
different because now Queen Elizabeth
isn't around to defend him any anymore
you know she tacitly acknowledged that
this was true by removing him from
public life you know she said you're not
in the Christmas card anymore right you
still in a palace but it's a dinkier one
and you've got to get out of here he has
no one to Shield him anymore from what
he's done I also think it's an important
moment for local journalism and Julie K
Brown at the Miami heral deserves all
the props and all the shoutouts in the
world that you can possibly muster for
the backbreaking work that she did to
break the story originally to get
interviews for all of those women who
did speak out I think it was on Good
Morning America a few years ago that
that was happening um so support local
journalism and make sure that they are
getting the funds to do these
investigations and then what happens are
any of these people going to be
prosecuted further is that what's coming
down the pike for someone the question
is the statute of limitations the
question is the black book why is the
Department of Justice not revealing the
names and the black book why are they
keeping it sealed look we heard about
Senator George Mitchell we heard about
Governor Bill uh Richardson I mean you
don't want to see these names but he was
you're right he was running with people
in power but people in the banks and the
truth is that it was the Department of
Justice through Alex aosta who gave him
the deal of a lifetime took the case
away from the local da and instead of
investigating it for money laundering
and everything else when they had him
dead to they gave it back to the local
da and he got a slap on the wrist and if
you remember that case that was the one
where he gave people uh immunity for imp
perpetuity for life right oh the hunter
Biden
immunity they quite as good and by the
way NECA Wafers are actually pretty good
you would say that best thank the best
we're gonna get some hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else